اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من تل ابيب اهلا بكم
وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه تكشف عن اصابه 5000
جندي وضابط منذ بدء الحرب الفان منهم
اصبحوا معاقين في وقت اعلنت فيه القسام
تدمير عدد كبير من الاليات الاسرائيليه
خلال الساعات الاخيره ووقوع قوتين خاصتين
اسرائيليتين في كمين في حي الشيخ رضوان
ومنطقه
الكرامه شهداء وجرحى في قصف اسرائيلي
متتالي على مختلف انحاء غزه والذي استهدف
مناطق ماهوله بالسكان في دير البلح وسط
القطاع وخان يونس ورفح جنوبا كما وصل اكثر
من 130 شهيدا ومئات المصابين الى مستشفيي
شهداء الاقصى وناصر خلال الساعات
الاخيره انسانيا مجمع ناصر الطبي يعلن
عجزه امام الاعداد الكبيره للمصابين
ومسؤول اممي يحذر من ان نصف سكان غزه
يتدور نجوعا ووزاره الصحه في غزه تقول ان
الاحتلال يحاصر مستودعات الادويه المركزيه
بينما وصفت اليونيسيف غزه بانها المكان
الاخطر على الاطفال في
العالم وفي الضفه الغربيه الاحتلال يعدم
شابا في الخليل ويواصل حمله الاعتقال
كما اعلن عن اصابه جندي على الاقل في هجوم
على حاجز عسكري غرب جنين من جهتها اعلنت
كتيبه جنين مسؤوليتها عن الهجوم واكدت
سقوط قتلى وجرحى الى
اللقاء